ladies are waiting for you in the
peacock room don't you love marco i love
you i love white elephantine all year
long because i love to give gifts
there's always a great banter around the
gift giving kind of tells a lot about
people's personalities i think so tamara
what are you gonna pick from this oh boy
little
we're missing brandy
[Music]
open it let's see what she's going to
pick the gucci box because that's from
eva i could
i
tell
that i feel like someone's gonna steal
it from me i know
it's definitely going who's got number
two
brandi
i think you should marco somewhere we're
waiting on you no stop it do you have
your number i went pee that's it okay
brandi's up next she's got number two
strangely she's number two you get to
open so you can either take her through
juice
i'm gonna choose something new oh good
adventure i like that
[Music]
i like thank you jesus i like a little
box oh god i like your little box too
it's right my face she likes a little
tight box so that's from taylor that's
ironic because you're drawn to my energy
we have made out before it's super fast
oh i love you thank you well no don't
get too excited because i take it
[Music]
okay then
like wow if randy doesn't stop someone's
gonna get pregnant what is it
i have no idea it's christmas the drinks
are flowing
pillow lips it was bound to happen
oh this is the best
[Applause]
as a jew i want to say i love the ugly
christmas sweater because i never got
one thank you dorinda two sunday silks
collection
oh that's a great gift
that's a great gift
that's a great gift brandon i'm number
five and i'm stealing the fake scarf yes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know i love you girl but brandi
picked you before me and the sex thing
so that's what happened
who's number six
oh i want this well that's vicky
oh my gosh
i love that oh this is the camera it
feels so good i wanted to see it
it's an iphone election no it's not
it's an eyewear smart oh these are my
glasses that are bluetooth you can hear
like sunglasses dictate for your workout
for derobic oh no one can take this and
i'm going to get tamara's because i need
this i'll really what is camera
a vibrator you better have breath of
double lace baby doll it's a billion
what is it oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
when you take a bunch of middle-aged
women
and put them in a room it spells
vibrator
you like it there's a vibrator
in the chicken what a vibrator will
sneak into the situation no matter what
it is tamara you can go back to anyone
and you can either take this gift
or you can take something back and then
that person gets that gift
[Music]
like you did last night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
put your baby back girl get your baby
back that means you end up with this
you absolutely deserve it i'm not
exactly sure how white elephant works
but i don't think they're stealing bat
um of course leave it to these girls to
break the rules even white elephant on
christmas
[Music]
you